all right the VD of the left they are
going insane tonight over reports that
the North Korean dictator little rocket
man Kim jong-un is threatening to pull
out of the plan June 12 summit with
President Trump over u.s. and South
Korean military drills
now Kim jong-un also reportedly canceled
pre-planned talks with South Korea now
before all of you left-wing liberal
activists work yourselves into a frenzy
let me give you the truth and some facts
the State Department and Heather an hour
is saying that this summit in Singapore
is going on as planned that's one and
the Pentagon is adding that these
military exercises are going to continue
the big takeaway that the left refuses
to understand is this President Trump is
already winning without giving anything
up in return so you idiot ideologues in
the destroy Trump media you'd need to
watch learn how to negotiate let's see
the president got three American
hostages out and he didn't have to send
over cargo planes full of cash and other
currencies like Barack Obama did with
the mullahs new satellite images are now
showing North Korea is already
dismantling their nuclear test site and
as we have told you Kim jong-un is
inviting the Western media to watch as
he decommissions that nuclear facility
also Kim jong-un guess what Wow
he's no longer firing missiles over
Japan he's not threatening Guam he's not
threatening the continental US and the
rest of the world and yes you saw it
with your own eyes well little rocket
man walked across the DMZ to greet South
Korea's president and what a president
Trump gave up and returned for all of
this
nothing President Trump is not naive
like Bill Clinton Barack Obama they
tried to bribe these desperate sand
dictators with billions and hundreds of
billions of dollars what we're seeing
here is typical quintessential Reagan
trust but verify in action before your
very eyes
now if Kim jong-un wants to come to the
table then fine we know the Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo he has laid out all
the details all the terms for a possible
agreement and that includes complete and
total denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula and a little Rocket Man
doesn't want to comply well then he has
to face the
consequences and President Trump has
made clear North Korea is not going to
get away with threatening the world and
he will never be able to fully develop a
nuclear weapon here's my prediction
tonight Kim jong-un well he's being a
little petulant he's posturing he's
doing a little saber rattling before he
ultimately capitulates goes to the table
now even more breaking news to tell you
about tonight president Trump's attorney
Rudy Giuliani the former New York City
Mayor he's telling NBC News that he has
spoken with Muller and his partisan team
of witch hunters in the past 24 hours
he's now saying that a potential
presidential interview is being put in a
holding pattern which is great news
Muller has no business ever questioning
the President of the United States
there's no such thing as collusion
although there might be with Muller and
that oligarch I'll explain now remember
the leak special counsel question asking
Trump what he thought how he felt how
did you feel well those are ridiculous
questions Muller is clearly setting in
that case of perjury trap no good lawyer
would let the president be interviewed
under those conditions and also tonight
the president he's continuing to keep
his promises to you the American people
The Forgotten men and women that the
media never thought would show up in
November of 2016 and he's now calling on
Congress to do their job secure the
border do it now
take a look the first duty of government
is to protect our citizens and the men
and women of DHS are on the front lines
of this incredible heroic fight that is
why we are calling on Congress to secure
our borders support our border agents
stop sanctuary cities and shut down
policies that release violent criminals
back into our communities we don't want
it any longer no we don't we need to
protect the American people now
President Trump he has already
accumulated an amazing record of
accomplishments for every Republican if
they're smart that they can run on in
November
and this would just be another key
victory look at the economy record low
levels of unemployment optimism at
11-year high the president's poll
numbers the highest he's had in his
presidency and there's their promises
that are kept on the Iranian deal on the
embassy in Jerusalem on tax cuts on
killing the Obama care individual
mandate and there are positive results
all over the place and by the way it
hasn't even been two years also tonight
this is major the Russia collusion hoax
is unraveling as we predicted right
before our eyes
the House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez he is offering up
new proof that the entire thing has
always been a witch hunt chairman Nunez
is now saying that there was never any
credible evidence for the FBI to begin
probing the Trump campaign now we know
there was a spy supposedly on top of the
FISA abuse he never had any right to do
this in the first place take a look we
have yet to see any credible evidence or
intelligence that led to the opening of
this investigation
I believe they never should have opened
a counterintelligence investigation into
a political party counterintelligence
investigations are are you know very
rarely do they happen and when they do
happen right you have to be very careful
because you're you're using the tools of
our intelligence services and
relationships with other countries in
order to spy on a political campaign
probably not a good idea the powerful
tools of intelligence used to spy on an
opposition party candidate and those
powerful tools used against Americans no
that can't happen here so there was
never any actual credible evidence to
launch this investigation and of course
fraud Rosenstein conflicted this is a
stunning statement by Devan newness and
that's on top of of course the FBI the
DOJ lying misleading FISA judges
multiple times in order to get a FISA
warrant to spy on a trump campaign
associate in the weeks leading up to an
election and for an entire year for
judges lied to they never would told the
truth they never told it was a bought
and paid for
Clinton dossier that was not verified
not corroborated and now there's a new
dynamic to this massive scandal now the
possibility of an FBI mole that was
inside the Trump campaign now chairman
Nunez is now investigating this huge
development take a look you had fusion
GPS that was hired by the Democratic
Party in the Clinton campaign to draw up
a dossier on the president or on as the
president was running for president what
happened with that is is that in his
testimony he mentioned that there was a
source within the campaign Glenn Simpson
fusion Simpson said that in public tour
what was close testimony then it became
public now he's confirmed that he was
telling Congress the truth which is
probably a good idea we believe he was
telling the truth and what we're trying
to do is get the documents to figure out
you know did they actually have what
methods were used to open this
counterintelligence investigation that
is an amazing statement we have been
saying that this scandal is the biggest
abuse of power scandal and corruption
scandal in American history and that we
have been uncovering this and peeling
back the onion this is only the
beginning you got to sit tight and
buckle up because everything that the
media the Democrats have been telling
you for well over a year is now getting
flipped on its head and all of it as we
told you at the beginning of this year
is boomeranging back on them now while
the real Russia scandal is expanding
well Robert Muller's witch-hunt is
crumbling now it's reaching embarrassing
levels let's sort through some of the
recent headlines at Muller's probes
first trial expect more blunt lectures
from the bench now that Judge TSL us the
third already Smackdown in epic fashion
Muller's team calling them out for
trying to flip Paul Manafort on an
effort unrelated it had to do with the
Ukraine and tax fraud from 2005 what
does that have to do with Trump Russia
collusion The Washington Times indicted
firm Muller trying to justify his own
existence and indict a Russian any
Russian these court transcripts
reportedly show Robert Muller indicted a
Russian company it didn't exist at the
time they said now this is now showing
that Muller's original indictment was
nothing
more than an illusion to make it seem
like there was some sort of Russia
collusion Muller never anticipated that
the Russians were going to call his
bluff this is a huge embarrassment for
him and now there are those special
counsel they look foolish because his
team was never prepared as Andy McCarthy
said it was all for show
Byron York out with this piece one year
down and it's still Muller time and he
writes that Russia probe has now been
going on for almost three years and
there is not one indication what this
entire investigation is really about now
here's what we do know after all of this
time there is zero evidence of Trump
Russia collusion it's been a witch hunt
it is a witch hunt and it is a total
sham and for the sake of the country it
needs to end and then we have key
updates to John Solomon's explosive
report that we brought you last night
about the FBI director Muller actually
working with the Russian billionaire
Oleg Deripaska is his name now part of
the investigation he was working with
him now there's absolutely nothing wrong
I'm gonna defend Robert Muller on this
he and other FBI agents they were trying
to free a former FBI retiree a CIA
operative
his name is Robert Levinson from Iran he
was being held hostage now I'm happy
that he was working with the Russian
billionaire the oligarch that he somehow
convinced the oligarch to give him
twenty five million dollars to help save
an American being held hostage I have no
problem with that at all the government
should do everything possible in that
situation I'll give them all the credit
it was the right thing to do here's the
issue it's just a massive conflict of
interest and that's what we're calling
mullahs Russian collusion here you know
what if you're gonna talk about it a guy
in a metaphor case that you worked with
that you secured twenty five million
dollars from I think you need to reveal
something like that
now John Solomon reporting tonight that
that Russian oligarch is one of the
first people the FBI actually
interviewed when they began
investigating the Clinton bought and
paid for dossier and as Solomon and
others are now exposing the Russian
actually told the FBI the idea of
Russian collusion was false so now the
question is did the FBI tell the FISA
courts that a former trusted source of
the
told them that there was nothing to this
Russia collusion when they were applying
for those four FISA warrants the
original application and three
subsequent applications all using the
bulk of information from the Clinton
bought and paid for unverified dossier
with Russian lies they lied about it
to the FISA Court to spy on an American
citizen an opposition party campaign
member now another developing story to
tell you about tonight the meeting
between the DOJ in the house committee
chairman Devin Nunez and trey Gowdy that
was reportedly scheduled for next week
well that's not happening
why newness and Gaudi were again
supposed to see the 1.2 million
classified documents and information
that they have been requesting about the
Russia investigation at this hour it's
unclear what this meeting is no longer
happening but what is clear is that rod
Rosen Stein the Department of Justice
they have been stonewalling Congress
every single step of the way
and the DOJ is also trying to sabotage
the work that people like Nunez
Goodlatte Gowdy are doing with anonymous
leaks they want to slow roll this until
the midterms hoping Nancy Pelosi and the
Democrats take over the house so then
they won't reveal any of this now also
tonight Fox News is learning that
Congress has received information from
the DOJ that it requested regarding
commis buddy remember that that
Professor / Columbia University now his
attorney Daniel Richmond remember he was
a special government he had special
government employee status former Obama
deep state DOJ official Sally Yates she
interestingly she's going after the
president claiming that he's quote
tearing down the legitimacy of the DOJ
Sally you're probably watching but you
and the rest of your deep state cronies
you have already done enough damage and
in a sad part is a rank-and-file FBI CIA
intelligence their reputations are
smeared because a deep state operatives
at the upper echelon and the misdeeds
that they did in all of this that we
have now proven on the show and maybe
Sally you're forgetting you were
emailing with Muller's pit bull Andrew
Weissman and Yates is also one of the
corrupt officials that signed off on at
least
one of the FISA warrants that was
unbearable uncorroborated so
congratulations Sally you've done enough
damage to the DOJ more than any
president ever could and one more thing
tonight
Trump aiding former CIA director John
Brennan is being called out by two of
his former colleagues over his public
statements about the Clinton bought and
paid for dossier Paul Sperry reporting
the two former top officials are
actually contradicting Brennan's claim
that the dossier did not play a role in
the intelligence community's assessment
of Russian election meddling now Sperry
is pointing out that former NSA director
Mike Rogers told Congress the dossier
did in fact play a role in the Intel
assessment a former Director of National
Intelligence James clapper admitted
something similar to CNN and we know
clapper and Brennan are both lied so it
looks like Brennan once again is caught
lying now I guess this isn't surprising
from a guy who once voted for the
Communists for president of the United
States how we ever got that position is
beyond any understanding I have anyway
finally tonight last thing President
Trump is on the verge of another huge
victory this is good news for all of us
Gina Haskell now has the votes to be the
next CIA director and the fact that it
took this long just a few weeks ago
Democrats for them to support her now is
pretty disgraceful in their part Gina
Haspel was an American Hero
she helped keep us safe after 9/11 she
helped get the intelligence to find bin
Laden and here's another fact the left
will never admit enhanced interrogation
of the three people under medical
under medical supervision worked it gave
us the valuable Intel allowed us to get
to the courier which took us right to
bin Laden Democrats should have been
praising Haspel actually they were at
the time because she's more than
qualified